in the ending credits for blackfish it
reads that SeaWorld repeatedly declined
adding comments for the film can you
tell us when you initially contacted
SeaWorld it was very early on in my
production in the production so I
started in 2010 and sort of developing
the script and as soon as we started
filming I contacted them and for about
six months they kind of entertained well
maybe you know at least told me they
were entertaining the thought of me
being of them being a voice in the film
and then declined about six months later
did they see any footage did these have
they seen the film work um no no they
didn't see if the footage I did give
them a list of the questions that I
would ask and told them you know briefly
but that I had at this point interviewed
more critics I think of a lot of things
that have that have been going on in the
park then I have you know folks who were
speaking for on behalf of SeaWorld and I
thought I thought it was worthy for them
to weigh in and it would be valuable but
out but they declined Gabriella
how many times did you contact SeaWorld
um numerous times I think I contacted at
least throughout that six months I would
contact for follow up and then I would
try other people who speak on behalf of
SeaWorld who might not necessarily be
working there and so I contacted other
people so throughout that six months
countless times and now that the film is
gaining steam any comments from SeaWorld
a few comments I think in the press
about how the film does not talk about
how they really care about their
trainers and their animals so sort of
some I think you know general media
comments that we've heard so far
you